[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes de la tnt voici tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité
la semaine dernière était une semaine
d'hommage national à samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire géographie
décapité le 16 octobre 2020 près du
collège où il exerçait à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines vous verrez dans ce journal le
récit des commémorations avec que telle
et 78 il ya 15 jours s'est ouvert en
allemagne un procès qui doit durer trois
mois celui de joseph schultz un ancien
gardien de camp de concentration
l'une est accusé de complicité
d'assassinât
parmi les parties civiles des
descendants marseillais et la provence a
recueilli les témoignages que vous
verrez nationale dans ce journal nous
vous amènerons à qui on ville découvrir
des champions de formule 1 miniatures et
vous verrez ces bolides de n'ont rien à
envier aux grands bolides et non pas 30
ans et ils ont dressé déjà une liste de
99 choses à faire avant de mourir dont
confrères de télé pas aisée en corse ont
rencontré ces jeunes étonnant
je vous le disais dans les titres de ce
journal la semaine dernière un hommage
national a été rendu à samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire géographie
décapité le 16 octobre 2020 près du
collège où il exerçait à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines
le récit des commémorations par célia
cazaute angot patrick jacques de dixmude
et grégory canal de tv 78 sur place
dès le vendredi 15 octobre les
établissements scolaires ont rendu
hommage à samuel pâti comme au collège
jean zay à verneuil sur seine lors d'un
cours d'histoire géographie et
d'enseignement moral et civique une
classe de 3e a travaillé sur deux thèmes
de réflexion nous avions décidé de nous
intéresser plus particulièrement à ce
que fait le professeur d'histoire
géographie qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qu'on apprend en histoire géographie et
pourquoi en étudier l'histoire
géographie samuel tu fais mardi à jamais
minauder et c'est donc ici dans notre
collège
danton collège saluer qu'il nous
semblait évident que devant gros match
c'est au collège du bois donne de
conflans sainte honorine qu'une grande
cérémonie d'hommage à samuel papier
était organisée à huis clos samedi 16
octobre professeurs personnels éducatifs
et élèves ont pris la parole le ministre
de l'éducation nationale était sur place
un sentiment d'avoir de solidarité avec
la famille de sa vie la fatigue avec ses
proches avec ses collègues avec ses
élèves tous les professeurs de france
aussi est au fond avec tous les français
parce que c'est tous les français qui le
jour de sa mort il ya un an était
totalement bouleversé par ce qui s'est
passé et quand il ya une mort aussi
tragiquement aussi absurde c'est notre
unité qui lui permet elle qui permet de
lui donner un sens à l'issue de ce
premier hommage une marche blanche est
partie du collège jusqu'à la place de la
liberté un discours a été donné par le
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine ému
par l'événement le 16 octobre 2020
restera un jour à jamais marquée d'une
pierre blanche dans l'histoire de
conflans sainte honorine je pense que le
sens de cet hommage c'est à la fin d'un
âge assez mais elle pâtit et en même
temps un moment de rassemblement
indispensable pour qu'on puisse en
ensemble échanger discuter et rester
sous l'eau un monument en forme de
livres ouverts a été également dévoilé
symbole de la liberté d'expression des
centaines de personnes étaient présentes
c'est vraiment très très lamentable
on pourra jamais ses fins d'ailleurs on
pourra pas l'oublier non plus apporter
eux
mon soutien un soutien moral surtout à
la famille à la commune un square a
également été nommé samuel pâti en face
de l'université la sorbonne à paris
voilà sans transition est tout à fait
autre chose dans l'actualité il ya 15
jours s'est ouvert en allemagne un
procès qui doit durer trois mois celui
de joseph shoot 101 ans un ancien
gardien de camp de concentration qui est
accusé de complicité dans l'assassinât
de 3500 personnes et parmi les parties
civiles les descendants du marseillais
francesco qu'au mental et philippe
laurenson de la provence a recueilli les
témoignages de sa fille rose marie et de
son petit fils fernand écouter ces
témoignages toute la famille a été raflé
le grand père la grand mère et les
enfants ils étaient six trois frères et
trois soeurs qui est c'est enfin son
parti et ma grand mère à elle est
revenue avec ce tout ceci sa femme et
lui se remarie qui avait disparu ne
savait pas à l'époque ce qu'il était
advenu aulas l'a longtemps cru qu il
allait revenir j'aurais attendu pendant
des mois des années on essaiera quand je
suis avec ma mère et mon père était de
l'autre côté mais juste et pas ouverts
parce que j'ai jamais été voir vérité
mais lui il savait alors oui d'après lui
il était passé sous des pins des arbres
de teigne et dans les arts d'angers
beyamena les cacahuètes qu'on appelle un
pays qui y règne et moi mon père a sommé
de la combyre est rien car il faisait
griller et en faisait des parcs et puis
après il me le soir quand il venait me
le donnait à moi comme la face à la
distribution avec un guérisseur elle est
née par contre on avait la voix là nous
nous rendons en occitanie maintenant
dans ce journal et ce pour deux bonnes
nouvelles depuis quelques jours les
cinémas de nîmes se veulent plus
accessibles aux personnes en situation
de handicap
regardez comment ils s'y sont pris
explications de l'orissa merlas devient
occitanie sur place
ce dimanche matin au cinéma se joue une
séance un peu particulière
le son est moins fort que d'habitude
le film sous-titré est tapi dans l'ombre
des bénévoles sont disponibles pour
parer à toute éventualité
c'est le concept de cinéma différence
une association nationale qui débarque
dans les salles obscures de nîmes
objectif rendre le cinéma accessibles
aux personnes en situation de handicap
le handicap peut entraîner des
comportements qui sont un petit peu
atypique d'habitude dans les salles de
cinéma surtout les personnes autistes
les personnes polyhandicapées ou avec un
handicap intellectuel qui font que au
moindre comportement m'a qui sort un
petit peu de la norme d'habitude ça peut
être un cri une vocalisation un besoin
de bouger on s'attire les règles les
regards voir les réflexions des autres
spectateurs donc du coup bien souvent
les personnes concernées et leurs
familles malause plus à l'est dans les
lieux culturels parce qu on y va avec la
boule au ventre et ce qui est une sortie
normalement famille de plaisir au cinéma
à se transforme un petit peu en stress
donc l'idée c'est de créer des séances
où chacun est le bienvenu et chacun peut
exprimer ses émotions à sa façon et
vivre le film à sa façon voilà nous
quittons l'occitanie pour la bretagne
dans ce journal et avant que le chantier
du parc éolien de la baie de saint
brieuc ne ferment le temps de la période
hivernale il ya vingt blues de tébéo la
chaîne du groupe le télégramme a
embarqué avec les équipes dn marines et
leur nom leur mission évaluer les
conséquences de ces aménagements sur la
biodiversité regardez ce reportage
elle marine a présenté ce mardi son
dispositif pour évaluer les effets du
chantier du parc éolien de la baie de
saint brieuc sur la biodiversité un
budget de 8 millions d'euros sur trois
ans et des équipements comme ce bateau
scientifique
c'est un bureau d'études
qu'ils s'appellent c'était qu'une vivo
qui fait des suivis sur la ressource
halieutique donc ça peut considérer
années aussi bien la coquille
saint-jacques que des espèces de
poissons que que des espèces de bivalves
et donc en l'occurrence aujourd'hui là
en train de suivre ces bivalves donc il
fait des prélèvements sur le fond des
études réalisées une vingtaine
d'endroits dans le parc éolien et dans
un rayon de plusieurs kilomètres autour
du site des bouées mesure aussi le bruit
et la turbidité du chantier et les
premiers résultats sont rassurants à ses
distances là on a déjà perdu 50 décibels
on n'est pas sur des niveaux sonores en
fait qu'ils sont qui sont inquiétants en
fait comparé à ce qui est fait dans les
dents les travaux les travaux portuaires
ou des travaux en mer est même comparé
en fait tu as des as dévoué de bateaux
auxquelles sont soumis les animaux
marins une incidence faible sur
l'environnement de quoi rassurer
pêcheurs et opposants à ce projet éolien
mais du côté d'elle marine l'enjeu est
ailleurs
eboué bruit c'est pas quelque chose qui
était prescrit initialement dans nos
autorisations c'est quelque chose qui a
été discuté il y avait un manque de
connaissances sur ce sujet là est donc
l'objectif est vraiment d'améliorer la
connaissance et d'apporter des résultats
concrets elle marine poursuivra ses
études tout au long de la construction
puis de l'exploitation du site les
soixante deux éoliennes de la baie de
saint brieuc devrait être mise en
service en décembre 2020 trop nous
l'avons déjà évoqué dans ce journal ce
mois d'octobre est le mois de la
sensibilisation au dépistage du cancer
du sein il faut savoir qu environ en
france 30% des femmes ont recours à la
reconstruction mammaire après une
mastectomie parmi elles des clientes de
marion vous allez voir une tatoueuse du
mans qu'a rencontré margot bianco pour
alerter les sarthe regardez
sous les aiguilles de marion se décide
en ornement particulier la réole ma mère
de nathalie retiré lors de sa
mastectomie le but c'est de donner un
aspect hyper réaliste et de maîtriser le
trompe l'oeil et ça se fait pas en deux
ou trois mois de formation en fait il
faut une une réelle base de dessins
bien acquis pour que ce soit que ce soit
possible et faisable
chaque jour marion se sert de sa
formation de graphiste illustratrice
pour jouer avec sa palette d'encre
contrairement à la dermopigmentation le
tatouage offre un résultat définitif en
deux séances il ya beaucoup plus de
délicatesse à avoir de précaution à
prendre c'est à dire que ça se fait pas
n'importe comment moi je demande je
travaille en partenariat avec des
chirurgiens ou un colloque qui valide le
fait que ce soit faisable sur les peaux
parce que c'est quand même des pots qui
ont été qui ont subi de la radiothérapie
de la chimiothérapie donc en effet elles
sont donc pas forcément lui la même
texture ni la même fragilité au
quotidien la tatoueuse se bat pour un
encadrement plus strict de la profession
pour ne pas mettre en danger les
clientes
j'avais toujours rêvé d'avoir un
tatouage avant jamais j'aurais pensé que
je rate approche pour mon mon mamelon
enfin et
je suis contente quand même nathalie
déclare un cancer du sein en mai 2018 et
c'est son chirurgien plasticien qui
l'orientent vers marion pour ce qui
s'apparente à la phase finale de sa
reconstruction après trois ans de combat
contre la maladie quand on m'a dit voilà
on va procéder à l'ablation du sein je
les ai très bien pris parce que je me
suis dit voilà ça va ça va être du
temporaire et puis dans quelques temps
je ferai la reconstruction alors je ne
connaissais pas la reconstruction du
mamelon b d'entrée de jeu j'avais
j'avais pensé à la reconstruction
mammaire visuellement et
psychologiquement et dans ce sont à
nouveau aux femmes et c'est important
tant que femme la page va se tourner
définitivement aujourd'hui quoi avec
sept dernières séances c'est pour moi du
tout si le tatouage dariole mamère
soulage ces femmes un autre combats
restent à mener celui de sa prise en
charge par le système de santé qui n'a
encore régis aucun remboursement pour
cette prestation
je vous emmène maintenant dans ce
journal à vosges les bains dans les
vosges rencontrer nos meilleurs amis
c'est là que des chiens qualifié de mort
dans son rééduquer pour devenir deux
gentils petits toutous c'est un joli
reportage de thierry là sont nés de 2000
kg 1 nos confrères de vosges télévision
sur place regardez près de 350 animaux
replacer dans diverses associations de
protection animale le refuge privé de
grives loca la vosges les bains a donc
récupéré ces deux mâles leonberg déjà
réservés par des particuliers ainsi que
shiva ils ne se mêlent leonberg
également qui attend d'être replacés
outre ces chiens le refuge a également
donné asile à 14 lapin et près de 90
poules de cette saisie ordonnée par le
procureur de la république le
quinquagénaire incriminé passibles de
plusieurs contraventions et pourrait
être placée sous tutelle ou curatelle
jugement en janvier prochain
c'est la plus grosse opération de
sauvetage d'animaux enregistré à ce jour
dans les vosges mais les cas d'abandon
et de maltraitance animale ne sont
malheureusement pas isolé ce que je
constate c'est qu'on est de plus en plus
à appeler sur des maltraitances et des
saisies dans les vols d élevage et
l'écho des chiens qui sont fracassés les
mairies en général qui nous appellent
pour récupérer les chiens ou les la
gendarmerie difficile humainement
difficile financièrement également pour
les responsables du refuge n'a aucune
subvention parce qu'aujourd'hui on
n'ayant pas encore reconnu d'utilité
publique il faut trois ans d'existence
et 200 adhérents pour espérer obtenir
des subventions d'état en fait ils ont
et à combien au nombre d'adhérents un là
on est à un peu plus de 70 mo qui est un
refuge spécialisés pour chien mord dans
un terme que n'aime pourtant pas
spécialement mais ils disent privat les
chiens qui arrivent ici parfois ils ont
mordu où ils ont mais l'erreur faut se
rendre compte que l'erreur n'est pas
qu'animal c'est pas c'est pas
entièrement plus à la fête du chien ça
peut être un environnement ça peut être
des mauvais gestes ça peut être plein de
choses comme ça et
les gens les gens se font souvent dans
l'idée qu'un chien qui a mordu remords
draps mois deux ans et demi j'ai replacé
quand même 87 chien
on a eu très peu de retour à l'adoption
d'ennui 4 sur ce site de la vouge les
boys ils sont actuellement 67 à espérer
des familles d'accueil bienveillante
maintenant le coup de projecteur de ce
journal sur une amiénoise de 21 ans son
nom et ma fatigue et de se sentir en
insécurité lorsqu'elle faisait du sport
en solo elle a eu l'idée de créer une
association de femmes qui se retrouvent
une fois par semaine pour courir
ensemble géré montbron de wéo la chaîne
de la voix du nord a pu assister à leurs
entraînements hebdomadaires regarde
le concept c'est qu'on laisse personne
tout seul pendant la course si bon bah
y'a quelqu'un qui courent moins vite
voici le lait c'est quand même une au
moins une personne avec elle elles ne se
connaissent pas pourtant ces femmes se
réunissent pour une séance de sport en
groupe et en sécurité je préfère
vraiment être être en groupe
après la motivation parce que quand on
est tout seul quand on ait envie
d'arrêter on a les copines qui motive et
on
courir ensemble pour se sentir libre et
à l'abri c'est le mot d'ordre de celles
qui se font appeler les renarde chaque
semaine le temps d'un jogging
l'association réunit celles et ceux qui
craignent de pratiquer une activité
sportive seul et en l'extérieur celles
et ceux qui chaque jour subissent les
regards les mots les gestes déplacés à
quelques semaines y avait une un
événement à la hotoie et il ya des
personnes qui sont permises de nous
interpeller deux manières gentil mais
c'est pas agréable en tant que femme à
entendre et du coup le fait d'être seul
sait jamais très rassurant parce qu'on
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer avec
tout ce qu'on entend c'est ça me fait
peur c'est pour rassurer ses proches et
ne plus avoir peur qu emma créé et il ya
un an les renarde aujourd'hui 700
personnes suivent l'association sportive
sur les réseaux sociaux la preuve d'un
réel besoin désormais les objectifs sont
multiples se préserver des agressions
physiques et verbales partager ses
expériences mais avant tout se défaire
de l'image que certains se font des
femmes aussi si elles sont en legging
dans la rue ce pas parce qu'elles
veulent attirer l'attention des gens
c'est jusqu'à ce qu'elles veulent faire
du sport et prendre soin de leur santé
et donc je pense que c'est une question
d'éducation et
et puis faut qu'on se mobilise plus nous
entre femmes et même pas entre femmes
entre humains pour se soutenir et faire
en sorte que et moins d'insécurité à
l'extérieur selon une étude menée par le
magazine runner's world en 2016 43% des
femmes assure avoir déjà été victimes de
harcèlement durant un jogging de leur
côté les renarde envisage la création
d'une application mobile pour que la
meute grandisse encore
mangez bien la cantoche
voilà et puisqu'on parle de courir on
pourra peut-être un jour y courir là
haut car il ya bien eu un lac sur mars
il y a de cela 3 6 milliards d'années
tout de même c'est ce que viennent de
confirmer les premiers résultats des
données fournies par le rover
persévérance envoyé en juillet 2020 sur
la planète rouge une découverte qui a
son importance comme l'expliquent
sylvestre maurice l'astrophysicien de
l'irap à toulouse au micro de clément
gaci de la dépêche du midi nos confrères
sur place
tout ça nous intéresse parce que d'abord
l'eau c'est le fil conducteur
de notre recherche l'eau liquide puisque
c'est le solvant de la chimie organique
la chimie du carbone qui est la chimie
du vivant et donc dans notre recherche
de traces de vie il faut encore on est
tous convaincus que ça pète ça va être
mieux à que pour moi c'est plutôt une
promesse de se dire on est au bon
endroit et on va maintenant actionné
tous nos instruments voilà nous partons
pour les antilles maintenant et pourquoi
pas devenir pilotes de drones c'est pour
faire découvrir ce métier en plein essor
que des formateurs sont venus à la
rencontre des lycéens de l'établissement
paulette nardal à ducos en martinique
des lycéens visiblement conquis comme
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage
signé ni vent le mar et loïc régis de
via à tv martinique sur place attention
au décollage je vous dirais que tout le
monde ont les crocs comme ça
la sensation d'avoir la tête en l'air
c'est celle conférée par le pilotage de
drones une première pour ces élèves qui
suivent l'option si l espace durant une
après midi ils ont pu manipuler eux
mêmes ces engins c'était vraiment un
super mais en plus en droit à tout on va
super bien la qualité au top des
connaissances de base sur les règles et
la législation qui encadre ces appareils
conseils pratiques les lycéens sont
encadrés par des professionnels le cours
de la journée donne des idées en suivant
les indications du de l'instruction
s'était plutôt plaisant si je pouvais je
j'achèterai un drone et je passerai la
formation moi je trouve que c'est super
je suis retenu que pour piloter un drone
y avait plusieurs législations vous
pouvez pas faire ce qu'on voulait et que
pour avoir sa licence il fallait passer
une petite formation qui était gratuite
et l'instructeur s'est retrouvé face à
des élèves motivés et intéressés la
discipline pourrait bien être une voie
d'avenir pour eux parce que les tenir
éveillé comme j'ai eu en classe pendant
une heure et demie c'est pas facile donc
c'est que ça les intéressait à la fois
parce que ces nouvelles techniques et la
fois parce que il faut pas se le cacher
comme c'est un métier d'avenir il ya de
l'argent à faire et tout le monde veut
travailler pour gagner sa vie la
découverte des métiers du pilotage et le
premier temps fort pour ses élèves les
deux prochaines étapes se dérouleront à
l'extérieur de l'établissement un projet
pédagogique tourner autour de la transat
jacques vabre lors de l'arrivée des
bateaux les élèves accompagneront les
professionnels responsables de la prise
d'image
voilà maintenant il s'agit toujours de
pilotes mais cette fois ci il s'agit de
pilote de course je vous le disais dans
les titres ils étaient près de 40 sur la
ligne de départ de la coupe de france de
voitures radiocommandées et cela s'est
passé à thionville au nord de metz
ghislain schumaker de moselle tv y était
pour nous regarder cette course pas
comme les autres
les voitures s'apprête à sortir des
stands attachez vos ceintures et rendez
vous au premier virage
[Musique]
sur la piste ces bolides peuvent
atteindre jusqu'à 80 kilomètres heure
cette voiture et celle de cédric prévost
double champion de france une réplique
qui n'a rien à envier aux voitures
grandeur nature il ya tout qui réduit de
l'échelle 1 à l'échelle 1 5e voilà au
niveau géométrie de voiture c'est
identique on ressent tous - corchia je
suis capable de dire à chaque mètre
comment et la voiture comment il réagit
ainsi de suite la compétition est
divisée en quatre catégories selon le
type de véhicule
cet après midi là les pilotes
s'affrontent lors des qualifications des
manches de qualification elle censure un
nombre de tours dans un temps donné qui
est de dix minutes or actuellement les
meilleurs fonds 27 tours entre les
courses les pilotes prennent soin de
leurs cylindrées arthur change les roues
de sa porsche miniature à 10 ans il est
l'un des meilleurs pilotes du circuit ça
me fait plaisir de voir qu'il ya du
niveau en face et que je me traîne pas
bah là j'ai fini deux fois 2e derrière
l'un des derniers champions de france et
j'étais vraiment pas loin et hier par
exemple j'étais devant lui le modèle
club thionvillois accueille la
compétition pour son quarantième
anniversaire l'association rassemble une
cinquantaine de licenciés passionné
c'est l'amour du pilotage de respecter
un circuit d'avoir la bonne trajectoire
alors vous n'avez pas la sensation de
vitesse mais les sensations au niveau du
pilotage sont les mêmes arthur et cédric
ont obtenu leur ticket pour la finale
mais pas de victoire à la clé le double
champion de france termine 10e pendant
que le benjamin du week end à accrocher
la deuxième place
voilà on reste sur les pistes dans ce
grand jt des territoires faut-il le
rappeler en 2024 sera donné le coup
d'envoi des jeux olympiques et bien la
piste flambant neuf de bmx tout juste
inauguré à limoges pourrait servir de
piste d'entraînement au champion c'est
ce que nous explique alain dru haut de
cet aliment jean-noël aquitaine
20% des 120 mille licenciés de la
fédération française de cyclisme sont
des pilotes de bmx avec sa nouvelle
piste limoges se classe dans le top 5
des circuits français avec 300 m de
développer une butte de départ à 5 m la
piste a été tracé par les auteurs de la
piste des jo de tokyo c'est une
discipline qui est en pleine évolution
est pire qu est une discipline qui est
dans l'air du temps aussi pour la
jeunesse donc pour nous c'est
extrêmement intéressant bien sûr on a
des objectifs avec cette discipline qui
sont des objectifs olympiques mais parce
qu'il faut en avoir pour faire rêver la
jeunesse aussi derrière et aujourd'hui
c'est des médailles qui compte pendant
sa première journée de compétition avec
une manche régionale sud-ouest et ils
mangent département à l'eau devienne le
club a reçu plus de 450 pilotes qui ont
apprécié les installations et le circuit
c'est un monde perdu bien avant donc
pour les petits
le fait qu'ils aient déjà des boss qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de rencontrer les
grosses bosses à zéro volume voilà on
est vraiment sur un circuit type
nationale
tant pis si le voilà beaucoup
d'adrénaline a dès le départ on est la
seule piste de bmx de ce niveau là en
nouvelles aquitaine sa nouvelle
aquitaine une des plus grandes régions
de france et la plus sportive aussi donc
maintenant j'avais dit au club avec cet
outil d'aller nous chercher des grandes
et belles compétitions et de former des
pilotes de rochas pilotes on compte
entre 3 caf accompagnateurs chaque
compétition assure donc des retombées
économiques à la ville d'accueil limoges
pourrait recevoir en amont des jo de
paris des équipes jaunes un pic à
l'entraînement voilà nous terminons ce
journal par reportage plutôt insolite je
vous le disais dans les titres jérémy
hugo et kevin trois jeunes ont listé 99
choses à faire avant de mourir ils ont
un peu de temps devant eux vous me direz
puisqu'ils ont entre 21 et 27 ans et
leur premier défi c'est partir à
l'assaut d'un chemin de randonnée
particulièrement difficile peut être
même l'un des plus difficiles d'europe
qui se situe en corse angèle ricciardi a
rencontré pour nous deux de ces drôles
d'aventuriers pour vyas télévisé sur
place regarde
on a eu l'idée un peu de faire comme une
bucket list de choses qu'on veut faire
avant de mourir et donc là ça serait le
premier défi des 100 sur notre liste et
donc chaque des fils à ce qui en fait un
reportage est donc le premier défi
conclut me ses cheveux le faire avant de
mourir c'est faire légèrement corse en
général on a plusieurs types de
réactions sont dit oh ah les basques et
bretons en haut les marins ça peut être
après tout et n'importe quoi après on
dit qu'on déborde et ses
[Musique]
légions je sais pas pourquoi mais les
gens sont encore plus à l'aise ouais
compléter franchement pour pour une
première impression pour une première
rencontre ça parce qu'on brise la glace
rapidement et les échanges sont hyper
fluide si c'est super cool si on veut
résumer très simplement c'est un peu une
sorte de reportage cinématiques
existe mais en gros c'est de très belles
images des images à ses cinématiques qui
donne envie de saint germain mais en
même temps c'est aussi un reportage des
interviews rencontre faire ressortir le
vrai contre la vie chère et la corse vue
par nos yeux parce que de bas c'est
notre métier et on vendrait faire du
reportage cinématographique qui se
laisse regarder tout seul la journée tu
étais au bout de ta vie tu as tu dis
pourquoi j'ai fait ça je comprends pas
c'est horrible et même si c'est
magnifique c'est aux riffs physiquement
et mentalement et le soir tu arrives to
donc tourner avec la même chose dont tu
ya des liens qui se sent fort c'est une
ambiance extraordinaire
nous on a l'impression de vivre enfin
d'être dans un pays différent chaque
jour c'est dire si c'était visage
impressionnante aventures en 3d costa
rica avant on tient on se croirait à
wayne je sais plus où ça c'est avec les
chevaux le là que là ça faisait un peu
islande irlande gaillon du caillou brut
à des étendues vertes des chevaux
sauvages et pour ça c'est des
universités qui nous a choqués je m'y
attendais pas
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de nous avoir suivi sur vos chaînes en
région de la tnt et sur tv5 monde on se
retrouve pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous et mon courage
[Musique]